-Now the Republicans have
a slim majority in the House,
they've made it clear
they will use that power
to protect Donald Trump
and go after Joe Biden.
And, to do that, they've put
several far-right extremists
who tried to overthrow
the 2020 election,
including
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
on key committees with the power
to investigate the White House.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
Republicans still cannot seem
to grasp the differences
between the small number
of classified documents
that were discovered
at President Biden's home
and office
and the much larger pile
of documents
Trump stashed at Mar-A-Lago
and refused to give back.
In fact, they keep asking
the same dumb question --
why won't the FBI search
Biden's home,
just like they searched
Trump's beach resort?
-What's real concerning to me
is how justice is applied
and is it applied equally?
Why do you raid President Trump?
-[ Southern accent ]
My concern is how
[ Laughter ]
there's such a discrepancy
in how former President Trump
was treated --
by raiding Mar-A-Lago,
by getting the security cameras,
by taking pictures of documents
on the floor,
by going
through Melania's closet.
-Alright, first of all,
Melania's Closet sounds like
a store you'd find at a mall
in the '90s.
[ Laughter ]
Wear the only clothes that
give you that Melania smile.
[ Laughter ]
They could've also called it
Cold Topic.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, I doubt Melania
only has one closet.
My guess is she has multiple
closets for clothes
and also a secret closet
that lets her escape
out the back, like...
[ Laughter ]
whenever Trump tries
to talk to her.
[ As Trump ]
Mel!
[ Laughter ]
Mel, I'd love to get
your thoughts
on this speech, Mel.
Mel?
[ Laughter ]
Mel, did you flee
to Narnia again?
[ Laughter ]
Give my best to Aslan.
Aslan the Lion.
We love Aslan the lion,
don't we?
[ Laughter and applause ]
We love him, don't we?
He came up to me once, folks,
big lion, strong lion...
[ Laughter ]
...tears running down his face
and onto his whiskers,
and he said --
I'll never forget it.
He said to me, "Mr. Trump..."
-[ Roaring ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Also, I don't have
any trouble believing
that Trump would hide classified
documents in a closet,
the way a teenager hides porns
in a shoebox.
[ As Trump ]
They'll never find this,
especially if it's labeled...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Gruff voice ]
That's how we hid porn
in the old days.
Back when we had
physical pornography.
Now, it's all digital, but you
lose that tactile experience.
[ Laughter ]
That's why people
are getting back
into analog media, these days.
You know how everyone's
collecting vinyl
and cassette tapes again?
Well, I just stayed
at a very classy Airbnb
in upstate New York
that had a beautiful
mid-century credenza filled
with vintage Hustlers.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll tell you,
there's nothing better,
after a long day
of apple picking,
than settling
into an Eames chair
with some good
old-fashioned pornography.
[ Laughter ]
And the articles!
[ Fresh laughter ]
Again, I cannot
underscore enough
how different these cases are.
Biden is discovered
and turned over
about 20 documents, so far.
And let's be clear --
documents he should not have!
While Trump had over 300.
Trump refused,
for more than a year,
to turn them all over,
lied about having
turned them over,
instructed staffers to lie,
moved them around,
claimed they were his,
and claimed he could declassify
them with his mind.
[ Laughter ]
He did the classic Trump thing
of trying every defense,
instead of just one.
[ Laughter ]
Just today, Trump claimed,
on his social media site,
that "Trump hating
Marxist thugs"
had planted
classified documents,
while also admitting he kept...
[ Laughter ]
Wait. I'm sorry, your story is
you kept an empty folder
as a cool keepsake?
Were they Lisa Frank folders?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Who keeps an empty folder
as a keepsake?!
When I left "SNL,"
I took plenty of keepsakes,
but one of them wasn't a stack
of loose-leaf paper
from the copier.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you guys remember
the famous cowbell sketch?
It was printed on paper,
just like this.
[ Laughter ]
Also, you don't get
to just take stuff
from the White House
as a cool keepsake.
It's a government institution
owned by the American people.
When you visited Philadelphia,
did you also try to take home
the Liberty Bell?
[ As Trump ]
Just strap it to the roof
of Air Force One.
[ Laughter ]
But the differences
don't matter to Republicans.
They've made it clear
they want to weaponize
congressional committees
to go after Biden.
In fact, the guy you just saw
in that last clip,
James Comer,
is the new GOP chair
of the House
Oversight Committee.
Last year, he told CNN
investigating Trump's
classified documents
was not a priority,
but now, investigating Biden's
very much is a priority.
So, CNN's Jake Tapper
asked Comer him to explain
the contradiction,
and he couldn't.
-What do you say to viewers
who don't understand
why President Biden's documents
seem like
a big priority for you,
but President Trump, who took
hundreds more documents,
did not comply
with the subpoena,
did not reach out
to the National Archives
or the Justice Department,
to say,
"Hey, we found these documents,"
it's not a priority?
Do you only care
about classified documents
being mishandled
when Democrats
do the mishandling?
[ Laughter ]
-Absolutely not.
Look, we still don't know
what type of documents
President Trump had.
-Yeah, we don't know exactly,
but we know they exist, right?
They released a picture.
You remember that.
This one, that looks like
it's from the
classified document buffet
at Mar-A-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
"I will have an omelet
with ham and cheese
and some of the
nuclear documents."
[ Laughter ]
Also, we don't know
every document Trump has,
but we don't know
what Biden has, either.
And, honestly, I'm shocked
Biden didn't just
throw them all out
because he definitely strikes me
as one of those old dads
who gets fed up
with all the [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
everyone else left in the garage
and throws it all in a Dumpster.
"Hey, Dad,
where's my old Schwinn?"
[ As Biden ]
Chopped it up with a saw,
threw it in the garbage.
[ Laughter ]
Needed room for my new Harley.
You should see your mother and I
pull up at Applebee's
on that thing.
[ Laughter ]
They give us free potstickers.
[ Applause ]
Trump, on the other hand,
strikes me as a hoarder.
I bet he still has every piece
of sports memorabilia
he's ever collected in his life,
no matter how worthless it is.
[ As Trump ]
This right here is very special.
It's a football signed
by Vinny Testaverde.
Not the Vinny Testaverde,
just a guy from Long Island
with the same name.
[ Laughter ]
Did the grouting
on my bathroom tiles.
Great guy.
Still haven't paid him.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, that's the new chair
of the powerful
House Oversight Committee,
which has the ability
to issue subpoenas
and investigate
the administration.
In fact, Comer just sent
a request
to the Biden administration
requesting visitor logs
for Biden's Delaware home,
which was an odd request,
given that people don't usually
keep visitor logs
for private residences.
I mean, I do,
but that's only so I
can remember all the celebrities
that stopped by
for my famous dinner parties.
Let's take a look
at the first page.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Anyway, it turns out that Biden
does not keep visitor logs
for his private residence.
-Some news this morning.
We are learning there are
no visitor logs chronicling
who comes and goes from the
president's house in Wilmington.
-Yeah, of course there aren't.
It's a house,
not a bed & breakfast.
[ Laughter ]
Although, I would like to see
Biden open up B&B.
[ As Biden ]
Alright, here are the rules.
Breakfast starts at 4:00
and ends at 4:30.
[ Laughter ]
The closest we got
to oat milk is
what's left over
after I eat my Cheerios,
so, unless you want that
in your coffee, shut your yap!
[ Laughter ]
At 6:00, we go out back
to chop wood
and then we spend the rest
of the day watching "Matlock."
Oh, and if you're interested,
there's Hustlers
in the credenza.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, real talk.
You want to know why there are
no visitor logs in Wilmington?
No one wants to admit
they were ever in Wilmington.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Hey, it's all jokes, Delaware.
You know I love you.
I love your beaches,
your corporate tax shelters,
and the Amtrak station
I pass through on my way
from New York to D.C.
It's like the commercials say --
Delaware.
It's better than Jersey.
Barely.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, those are the kinds of dumb
requests the Oversight Committee
will, apparently,
be obsessed with,
now that Republicans are
in charge.
The bummer is some actual
oversight would be great.
Congress should hold
the administration accountable,
regardless of party.
They should just do it
for real stuff
that people actually care about.
Instead, House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy
has appointed some of his
caucus' looniest weirdos
to both
the Oversight Committee,
where they will have the power
to investigate Biden;
and also the powerful
Homeland Security Committee.
-McCarthy made big promises
to Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
and Paul Gosar,
two hardliners, of course,
who were kicked off
of their committees
by Democrats last session.
They are back on some pretty
prominent committees, in fact.
Oversight,
the House Oversight Committee,
very, very powerful,
will now include
Marjorie Taylor Greene,
Lauren Boebert,
Scott Perry, and Paul Gosar.
So, again, some big
hardliner names
that are going to be serving
in a very powerful position.
-There is Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
There's Paul Gosar.
Those two were thrown
off their committees
in the last two years by the
Democratic-controlled Congress
for incendiary
an/or violent rhetoric.
They will get committee
assignments back.
In fact, we can confirm
that Marjorie Taylor Greene
will be on the Committee
on Homeland Security.
That's a coveted spot.
-That's right,
a bunch of people who tried
to overthrow the 2020 election
will now sit on major committees
with the power to investigate
the administration,
which, to me, does not seem
like a great idea.
It's like if you're a prosecutor
in a murder trial,
you wouldn't want
to show up to court
and see a guy in a hockey mask
sitting in the jury box.
[ Laughter ]
"Ah, son of a gun.
How did we miss him?"
[ Laughter and awws ]
It's especially insane
to put Marjorie Taylor Greene
on the Homeland Security
Committee,
given that she has
previously espoused
some pretty unhinged
conspiracy theories,
like the time she, of course,
claimed the 2018 California
wildfires were caused by...
[ Laughter ]
She shouldn't be on the
Homeland Security Committee.
She should be an actor
with one line
in the next "Avengers" movie.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Greene ]
Thanos is collecting
the sun's energy
and beaming it to the Earth
to cause wildfires.
Also, we think Thanos
might be Jewish.
"Cut!
[ Laughter and applause ]
That second part isn't
in the script."
I know, but doesn't it make it
[ Laughter ]
sound more believable?
Greene also spread
conspiracy theories
about everything
from the COVID vaccine to 9/11
and, when she was asked
about her past support
for QAnon,
she blamed the Internet.
-The Democrats stripped you
of your committee assignments
after you were elected.
-Right.
-That was raw politics.
-Mm-hmm.
-But, in fairness, didn't you
also say, around that period,
that you had been a follower
of QAnon conspiracy theories
and you had rethought this
and you were no longer
influenced by the group?
-Well, like a lot
of people today,
I had easily gotten sucked
into some things
I'd seen on the Internet.
-I'm not sure I'm comfortable
having someone
on one of Congress'
most sensitive committees
who gets sucked into things
they see on the Internet.
That's the same excuse
your mom uses
when she spends 1,000 bucks
on Candy Crush.
[ Laughter ]
Mom, again?!
"I got sucked into buying
more lollipop hammers,
so I could finally be
the Jelly Queen.
[ Laughter ]
Now, Venmo your mother
some money."
[ Laughter ]
But this was part
of the deal McCarthy made
with the crazies in his caucus
to become speaker.
Remember,
Greene threw her support
behind McCarthy specifically
because she wanted to get
on these powerful committees,
which she bragged about
in MAGA rallies
before the election.
-I'm looking forward
to Republicans
taking back control
in the House.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And I'm looking forward
to serving on committees.
-It is unnerving
when someone says the phrase,
"I'm looking forward
to serving on committees"
with that much glee.
It's like hearing someone say,
"I'm looking forward to visiting
Wilmington, Delaware."
I'm kidding, Delaware.
I love you guys.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Philly, on the other hand...
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump
tanked his party
in three successive elections,
leaving the GOP weak
and fractured,
but what we're seeing right now
in the House
are the last vestiges
of Trumpism.
McCarthy and the
far-right extremists
he's empowered in the House
have made it clear
they're going to use their
positions to protect Trump,
who stashed classified documents
the way a teenager would stash
a magazine called...
-Melania's closet.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Whistling ]